- Dans la cour d'un institutrner
des volontaires de la défensena.
Chacun veut prendre
une photo avec Oleg Skrypka,k nl
venu les soutenir.
(chant)ne de vieilles chansons
à la gloire de l'Ukraine comme
il le fait presque chaque jour
auprès des combattants.
C'est saà l'effà l'effà l'effà :
gonfler le moral des troupes.
- C'est mon arme, c'est
la guitare, c'est la voix,
c'est lec'est les chansons, c'et
l'accordéon... l'accordéon.
Et en plus, les artistes,
ils sont nés pour sentir
Et moi, depuis 20 ans, 25 ans,
je chante les chansons
militaires.
Andriy Khlyvnyuk a plutôt
choisi, lui, de prendre
auprès des jeunes, il estmainteé
de combat de la police. Il n'a
"Je suis Ukrainien, et l'Ukrains
ici, c'est ma ville, comment
(chant patriotique)
Au tout début de l'invasion,
lors d'une patrouille,
il a chanté un vieux chant
patriotique. La vidéo
- David Gilmour, du groupe Pink
Floyd, a été tellement touchéééé
qu'il a décide de reprendre
sa guitare.ey Rise Up"
est devenue un hymne
de la résistance ukrainienne,
et les fonds recueillis
seront vires.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais tout ça est bien loin déjà
pour Andriy. Il a ar un éclaar .
Et à ceux qui s'étonnent
qu'un artiste comme lui
soit prêt à tuer des gens...
... il rue à des humains,
qu'ici on détruit ceux qui
veulent vous tuer, ceux qui
bombardent vos enfants,
de la personne ni les règlesde .
♪ ♪ ♪
De son côté, Oleg a entonné
au plus grand plaisir
de ces v,,,,,,,
qui sont des civils
et qui chantent avec lui.
un moment, les horreurs
de cetteue la plupart
d'entre eux, le 24 février
dernier, ne pouvaient
- Cette guerre, elle est
C'est inc C'est inc C'est inc .
- Très dure...
- Très, très duEt le 24, 90 % d,
on croyait pas que
arriver comme ça parce que
c'est covenir d'un style du MoÂ,
envahir harsharsharsharsharshars
un grand pays.
- Avant de retourner a son
t a remercier
le Canada, qui lui a fourni
Le giletLe giletLe giletLe giles
lui a d'ailleurs sauvé la vie.
Et il a un dernier message.
Son unité a aussi besoin
d'équipement de vision nocturne.
La guerre est loin
Ici Céline Galipeau,
Radio-Canada, Kie